andrew heaney will turn 30 years old on
june the 6th against the blue jays he
pitched oh so effectively well six
innings without a run allowed and nine
strikeouts joe madden says he wants his
starting pitchers to be creative on the
mound
a high breaking ball elicits a swing and
a miss and garver goes down on strikes
that's the 13th time he has struck out
this season
breaks his bat they'll get one can they
turn it clutch under first that is a
double play
australian lewis thorpe
making his fourth career start
possesses a fastball curveball slider
and change up
using his legs getting stronger
swing i think he went
and the knight couldn't have gotten off
to a better start for lewis thor getting
stronger and also trusting himself in
the weight room
one and two to ohtani
out in front a little pop-up
and
sticking with it as polanco making the
catch
that's a good sign he's doing a lot of
strikes first pitch strikes
well wes johnson will take four or five
more of those like originally beginning
his career with the dodgers
at the pomona there's exactly what mark
and jose for that effect were talking
about
here's the 3-2
and he swings and misses a breaking ball
struck him out and the inning is over
brock was a tremendous job with the
minnesota twins
good looking breaking ball and blanco
right over the top of it
four strikeouts came all the way back
and then through a nice breaking ball
close enough where you have to go after
it as a hitter but it still gets to
chase just below the strike zone
2-2 pitch and that one there waved and
missed he struck him out and that will
end the inning
that was the first thing i would do
every year
paul hit two donaldson he'll get the out
there and they'll get the out there
suzuki bounces into a double play just
like that there are two down
no score in the third
and the 1-0 pitch a ground ball to third
towards the hole backhanded by polanco
low throw dug out by cino
on a hop for out number three
without those two strikes look at the
leg kick
ah interesting it's rolled out to third
they get one quick turn onto first in
time double play
fletcher got rid of it quickly it was a
beautiful feed by red heapho welcome
back to the big league that is an
incredibly difficult play for luis
friend hifo and not only makes the play
how quickly he got rid of the baseball
in the transfer and over the fletch who
was extra quick to be able to get a
double play i thought no chance double
play tough hop how quick he got rid of
it and then fletch five four three
double play what a job
to center field trout drifting tracking
here's mike trout at the plate
i drive crushed
into
that second tier did you think you were
nearly the upper deck did you think you
were gonna get a foul ball sitting down
there watching the game tonight he had
to look at that to see how far that went
he knew it wasn't going to stay there
but he's like wow
[Applause]
that's good you don't see a pitcher look
that long with a foul ball or even
anything hit hard what's he going to
fastball up
he went down and mike earns the walk the
12th time this year he has walked and
usually when that happens you never
regain your athleticism
so credit to him down the line speaking
of athletes upton on the run trout out
front they'll stop him at third justin
upton with the double now the angels
with two outs have two in scoring
position we'll see if
jared walsh can bring someone home
roll toward the hole into right center
field the angels with the couple on the
scoreboard and jared walsh gets it
some done out hitting a couple rbis a
couple quick outs trout works the wall
anytime you see that with a walk with
two outs down the left field line and
then the ground ball with the shift on
beats the ship jared wallace driving in
two giving him 12 on the season tying
shoei ohtani with top mark on the team
it's a nice job they're using the big
part of the field the money
parked to the field as we know joe
madden likes
slated to be back over the weekend
here's the pitch here's a ground ball
hit the third this might be another
double play second for one relay to
first it is
and in five innings the angels have
turned three double plays behind haney
tony la russa kind of refined the roll
to just one inning at a time
and domnack comes back after falling
behind suzuki to strike him out
3-2 pitch got him went right back out
there with the fastball they got
everything they wanted out of andrew
haney joe madden wants to match up
manage going forward
smash down the line garber has a hit
polanco will score
behind him kepler is coming home and a
big double by mitch garver to tie the
game at two so the twins here in the top
half of the sixth inning have tied it up
you know garber was ever able to come
through and see if donald trump do the
same a bullet up the middle
garver
being waved around he'll score and
donaldson delivers another solid hit
driving in a run and it's three to two
twins second and third no outs and mike
trouts at the plate
mike bouncing ball through that drawn in
infield it's a basin
fletcher scores ohtani to the plate with
the slide in there
mike trout again comes in a pair and
just like that the angels are back on
top it's 4-3
infield in and when you play that
midfield in it's got to be hit directly
at somebody to try to cut the run down
at the plate and this ball is hit harder
runners at the corners trying to add on
the next spatter will be david fletcher
runner is on the move what a beautiful
hit and run
you go ahead and pull that infield in i
am fletch
rbi hit for fletcher angel's add-on it's
now 5-3 runners everywhere for the
angels so that'll bring up upton who's
had a one for three night here's the
pitch and there's a ball blasted out
into left field it is out of here
he did bust the game wide open it's a
grand slam and now it's 9-3 angels
justin upton gets a hanging breaking
ball and he does exactly what you're
supposed to on a hanging breaking ball
[Applause]
that one down the line toward the corner
it goes
dawn
oh walshy you made it 10.
back-to-back angel homers
10 runs on the board now it's 10-3
[Applause]
ostadio
utility player here we go let's have
some fun
eased in there at 51
[Applause]
shot one out
[Applause]
see how easy pitching is everyone hey
throw strikes
one
two two
got him
big home runs by upton a grand slam
and also by walsh to follow it up the
story tonight